okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
and i think we have a number of
questions that came in to our form and
one saved up from
previous weeks so let's see what can we
start with here
there is one from frost asking is 10 a
special number in any way
why is scientific notation in base 10 is
just because we have
five times two fingers but lots of
flowers have five-fold symmetry and so
on
interesting question so how did we wind
up with five fingers for example
how does
five end up being
an important number in biology
uh with many things with uh with things
like five-fold symmetry or
five of something
you know the fossil record tells us
something about that
uh if we go back
um
i don't know
500 700 million years
to um the uh
like the pre-cambrian period
uh when there were when there was mostly
uh there was just life in the oceans and
so on and the question is what kind of
critters existed at that time and we
know from samples like there's this
thing called the burgess shale in canada
that has some very ancient organisms
that look really bizarre they don't look
like modern organisms at all but they
have all kinds of strange tentacles and
other structures on them
and a bunch of those organisms
don't have the five-fold symmetry that
we're used to today they don't have five
of things they have some threes and
sevens and and maybe nines and so on
and uh so it seems like there was a
competition in
early life
for sort of what was the best number to
have as
your well in the end for us number of
fingers but uh for other things kind of
um a number of segments or or number of
uh
number of things around a circle those
kinds of things and it seems like for
some reason
five won out now why did that happen
it could have been sort of purely
coincidental it could have been almost
an accident
it could have been
because somehow three is too few seven
is too many uh odd numbers are better
than even numbers because you don't want
things to sort of uh line up on the two
sides or whatever else
we don't we don't know um the fact that
we have uh
given that sort of we are
ten based
uh
you know we've got a lot of um uh tennis
in us so to speak uh it is only natural
that our mathematics
has reflected that
but
certainly not all mathematics and
history has worked that way for example
the first kind of mathematics that we
sort of systematically know about is
babylonian mathematics
from well now about 4 thousand years ago
three thousand years ago
and uh
that
in babylonian mathematics
60 was the main thing used it was like
you count up to 60 and then you use 60
as the next unit and keep going that 60
is where we got our minutes in an hour
and so on from
um and eventually seconds in a minute
um
it's also where
uh it was first assumed that there were
360 days in a year that's where we get
our 360 degrees in a circle from
um so
for for quite a while in the history of
mathematics base 60 was the thing that
was used and base 60 is very convenient
because
60 has many divisors that is there are
many ways that you can split 60
in halves and thirds in quarters and so
on and still end up with whole numbers
and that's useful if you're saying well
i've got uh uh you know i'll have some
amount of barley let's say and i want to
give a quarter of it to so-and-so and
and uh a quarter of it to somebody else
well it's still a whole number of pieces
of barley if you started off with 60
pieces of barley
in your in your original collection so
60 is very convenient from that point of
view
now
in
people uh
10
people occasionally say well a dozen is
a more convenient number to use for
various commercial purposes and so on
and uh uh in fact i think it's been sort
of going out of fashion but um uh quite
a few things are kind of sold by the
dozen sold by the 12 because again 12
has has
is three times two times two and that
means that it has it you can you know
divide it in two divide it in three
divide it in and four and so on and uh
you still got whole numbers and that's
convenient
now people
have uh occasionally proposed different
kinds of let let's change our our system
you know for instance some there are
ideas like you know isn't it awkward
that there are seven days in a week
let's change that to
some rounder number whatever that means
or let's uh change the number of uh you
know hours in the day months and the
year all these kinds of things i think
these are
cases where
perhaps um
uh just by virtue of uh familiarity um
it's it's uh sort of the numbers that
we're used to are the numbers that we'll
tend to continue to want to have
i i've
mentioned a number of times in in
england where i grew up the currency
used to be based on uh having uh
12 pennies and a shilling 20 shillings
at a pound
um and that was something which again
i suspect had grown up i suspect it was
a holdover from roman times
it had grown up because of this
divisibility property of those kinds of
numbers
now in in terms of
this there's this whole question about
metric units versus non-metric units
should we really be dealing with you
know 12 inches in a
uh in a foot
you know three feet in a yard
1760 yards in a mile these are very
weird numbers you know why not
as uh napoleon pushed back in 1800 or so
um have uh a metric system where
everything is based on on tens
um and in much of the world that's been
what's happened um but again sort of
there's a there's a weight of
familiarity
in uh in the us and the uk and so on to
keep uh these kind of traditional units
and i have to say that now that we have
uh computers to compute things it's
probably less important to worry about
um uh to the the fact that it's a little
messier to do these computations with
these mixed radix systems i mean in uh
usually when we're dealing with base 10
we have uh you know there's the ones
column ones digits the tens digits 100
digits and so on
when we're dealing with uh for example
traditional british currency it would be
the the pennies and then the then
there's a factor of 12 to the shillings
then there's a factor of 20 to the
pounds and so on and it's a mixed radix
it has does not have a fixed multiplier
for every successive digit
um
i think
it's it's always interesting to see
kind of in
in well from alpha we try and provide
answers in the sort of local units of
whatever country the person is making
the query from
and some things are rather easy to deal
with um lengths you know
uh feet and inches versus uh um meters
centimeters
uh temperature fahrenheit versus celsius
but there are some slightly more exotic
ones like air pressure
uh as you know quoted on on the weather
uh you know when people poke the weather
and so on there's a lot more diversity
in how that's quoted whether it's
millimeters of mercury
whether it's some
hectopascals whether it's some
of gosh what are the other ones some
atmospheres tore
which is millimeters of mercury and so
on it's kind of a strange country
dependent thing what that's quoted in
and there are just conversions between
those
let's see
uh
contributes this um
this
comment that impellicles apparently
believed that arms and fingers and legs
roamed around as separate creatures on
their own eventually merging into
into the um the creatures that won out
okay that's that's interesting it's it's
always interesting to see
in kind of uh
uh ancient writings this kind of how did
people imagine
that things came to be the way they are
you know what was the story behind you
know how did the zebra get its stripes
how did the leopard get its spots
um how did uh uh how did the you know
the moon end up being circular
when viewed from the earth all those
kinds of things and it's it's it's
always interesting to see
what kind of models and ideas people had
about how things came to be the way they
are um sometimes to us today
those models seem incredibly kind of
primitive and how could they possibly
have thought that
um i when i see those kinds of things i
i think to myself what of things that we
say today will at some time in the
future seem to to people then to be
similarly naive
um
well there's some questions okay there's
a biology question from aaron here
why are some animals cold-blooded
well first of all i should explain what
what that means
so things like
lizards insects well lizards let's take
lizards um
the
to be cold-blooded means that there is
no internal regulation of the
temperature of the blood
so for example in us humans
the
the typical temperature of our blood
typical sort of core body temperature is
roughly 98.6 degrees fahrenheit 37
degrees celsius
um
and uh we when we're sort of in our
normal operating conditions
uh we maintain that body temperature
that's maintained by i guess the
hypothalamus and the brain
is maintaining uh things are the the
main source of heat in our bodies is
well the brain is a big source of heat
but the main source of heat that
regulates things tends to be the liver
um and uh sort of producing it's has
chemical reactions going on that produce
heat
and the our brains regulate the um the
temperature of our of our bodies
and they do that by using the fact that
certain chemical reactions um uh have
the rates of those chemical reactions
depend on temperature and that's kind of
the way that we measure temperature for
purposes of of being able to regulate
our own temperature
and when we get sick for example
one of the ways that our body tries to
make it unpleasant for the for the
viruses and bacteria
is
to increase our body temperature to make
it more difficult for those things to to
replicate and so on um and that's
a mechanism that is mediated by our
brains
and that our immune system when our
immune system kind of
gets the the alert that there's an
intruder um it will tend to um
to increase body temperature i have to
say that the uh
many years ago i i managed to break my
ankle
doing something very stupid but that's a
different story
um the uh on on some ice um but uh
uh
i was i was
very
surprised to see that my
you know within a few minutes my body
temperature gone up to like 104 degrees
fahrenheit um and i did i
i just didn't know that when one had
kind of uh just trauma to one's tissue
like that
that um i you know i i guess it's kind
of a big alert
for the um uh
uh
innate immune system and so on to go and
start um uh generating cascades of of uh
of chemicals to sort of help heal the
site and so on and one consequence of
that is increasing body temperature
well this idea
of um
having regulated body temperature is
something that only the that's a recent
idea for you know birds and mammals and
so on and that's an idea that doesn't
exist for for reptiles for reptiles um
it's the the temperature
that uh
is is based on the the ambient
temperature they don't regulate their
own temperature and so that means that
you know if you if you keep lizards or
something they'll tend to get if they
get cold they'll tend to get very kind
of sleepy and if you put a heat lamp on
them they'll they'll suddenly um wake up
and act like a sort of humans with
coffee or something
um
the uh i think
that's that's one it's very curious that
if you look at the kind of tree of life
on earth
that there are these kind of discrete
divisions into things like you know
reptiles birds mammals now they're
obviously they're creatures that are
kind of on the edge where does it really
count as a mammal well it's it lays eggs
but nevertheless it's warm blooded and
etc etc so they're kind of corner cases
but for the most part the so the tree of
life breaks in these very very large
chunks
and often those large chunks are
associated with a particular innovation
but sometimes those those chunks there's
once you have one innovation it allows
other innovations
once you are able to you know
uh sort of um gestate your young
internally so to speak maybe that's
related to being able to have uh well
that's that the not quite being able to
have body uh regulation of body
temperature because that happens a
little bit earlier in the in
evolutionary history but um uh it's it
kind of feels like once you have a
certain innovation
that kind of opens up many possibilities
for how an organism should work so so
for example
if you're um
an insect or something you don't have
lungs that allow you to kind of suck in
air and bring um and
you don't have a
circulatory system that allows you to
deliver oxygen to all your tissues so
instead you just have these kind of
tubes that that
bring
that have to bring um
bring oxygen into tissues and there's a
maximum length to those that's
determined by essentially physical
constraints and so there's kind of a
maximum size that those organisms can
get to before they've had this other
innovation um that uh allows them to get
bigger and so i think there are often
these correlations between once you have
sort of one invention
then other inventions come along with
are made possible and it kind of reminds
one a lot of the history of technology
where kind of the idea of computers
suddenly opens up all these different
kinds of things and suddenly you can
have drones and you can have uh all
sorts of different kinds of things
um so that one innovation leads to kind
of a cascade of other innovations and i
think one sees the same kind of thing in
biological organisms and that's um uh
that's that's what what happens there
well let's see
uh
the questions here there's one from yun
here
can our wolfram physics project be used
to simulate models of new medications
for diseases
you know if you'd asked me that a couple
of years ago when we were first getting
ready to launch our physics project i
would have said absolutely not nothing
to do with it but actually now i would
say yes
there's some very close connections and
they're pretty interesting
so let me try and describe that a bit i
mean our physics project has to do with
understanding kind of the low-level
structure of our physical universe kind
of what is space made out of um how do
particles work how does gravity work how
does quantum mechanics work and so on
but one of the things that's come out of
that project
is this understanding of kind of the
formal structure
of
well
we think that space is made from this
very large number of discrete atoms of
space
that are all getting updated sort of
independently and that are getting
updated in these different there are
many different possible updates that can
happen
and somehow when we observe what happens
in the universe
we
are kind of straddling many of those
different possible paths of history
because we ourselves are kind of
branching into many different parts of
history just like the rest of the
universe does and so as we perceive the
rest of the universe we're kind of
conflating together those different
branches of history because those
different branches of history are also
part of us
so that whole rather complicated story i
call it kind of the multi-computational
paradigm for thinking about things this
idea of of things are there computations
going on they're just sort of following
rules computing the next state etc but
this is happening in multiple paths
and there's this kind of idea that you
have these multiple piles of history but
we are we as observers of that are kind
of sampling many of those parts and kind
of combining them together to conclude
what we actually perceive
so that whole story turns into kind of a
mathematical structure
of things called multi-way systems
and uh ultimately this thing we call the
ruliad which is this kind of entangled
combination of all possible computations
a very complicated sounding thing and it
is in a sense the most complicated thing
we can imagine in the universe
um and among the things that are in it
is our physical universe
but from all of that sort of complicated
story
comes this kind of formal
structure
this formalism for describing how
systems work
and
we applied that formalism in physics
and we can see kind of how that
formalism plays out how that formalism
gives us the notion of space the notion
of time
the notion of gravity things like this
but it turns out that formalism can also
be used in other places
and the fact that it's the same
formalism that's being used in other
places and in physics lets us do things
like take ideas from physics like ideas
like black holes and so on and
transport those to other fields
so one of the fields that looks to be a
place where you can transport it to is
thinking about molecular biology
so normally when we think about biology
it's we think about organisms and
creatures and all that kind of thing but
over the last 50 years or so a big part
of biology is molecular biology the
study of of the molecular structure of
biological organisms
and
we are
the and uh the the kind of you know our
organisms consist of cells within cells
there are little organelles that are are
the sort of the
the different functional parts of a cell
and
in general most of the cell is made up
from uh proteins which are long
typically big molecules that are made of
of uh separate units there are about 20
amino acids that are these kind of
clumps of atoms that combine together in
a sequence to form proteins and we
humans have i don't know 30 000
different kinds of proteins or something
um that are sort of uh maybe yeah about
that that are kind of that make up us
well
the um the question
that is sort of a key question in in
biology and in molecular biology is
all these proteins they are inside cells
and they interact with each other in
complicated ways and those complicated
interactions and their interactions with
the dna and our cells and all sorts of
other things
all those things uh make us alive and
make us be able to do all the things
that we can do
and the question is sort of what's the
way to describe what's going on there
we can say well for example a very
typical way that one describes things in
molecular biology is to say oh when
there's an increased concentration of
this thing it produces an
increased concentration of that thing
which decreases the concentration of
that thing and the result of that is
that one starts uh producing more of
some kind of chemical and that makes one
do this or that
um the uh that that that for example i
don't know i was mentioning body
temperature uh that increases your body
temperature or that makes you uh able to
be more active or it makes you um uh or
it um
uh produces um
uh uh produces things that allow your
brain to operate or whatever else
but so the question is kind of how to
describe
these processes in molecular biology and
what's very typical is that you'll have
like you know there's a there's a big
wall chart that i think one could still
get it's now in in two giant sort of uh
uh sections that shows kind of all the
pathways that are known pretty much
in in cells that exist in things like
humans
and there are pathways that are
associated with these kind of cycles
going from one chemical to another that
eventually produce energy there are
other things that are responsible for
the replication of cells other things
that are responsible for i don't know
immune response etc etc etc these
different processes that go on in
biology
and one is used to seeing these these
kind of descriptions of those processes
just saying
what really matters is the concentration
of these different chemicals
well
if you've been doing chemistry
oh i don't know 100 years ago or
something now
that would have been the story as well
that everything is about the
concentration of different chemicals and
for example when people have been
building chemical plants
that produce some particular kind of
kind of chemical the big story of
chemical engineering has to do with uh
we've got this concentration of this
thing and that produces a concentration
of that thing and so on um there's a
sort of a a little footnote in chemistry
which is the idea of catalysts
um where for example you can have
different chemicals and the rate at
which they interact depends on uh what
you can you can have some some solid for
example often the chemicals are are
liquids or gases and you will have a
solid surface and as the molecules kind
of get um attached to the solid surface
they line themselves up in such a way
that they can more easily interact with
another chemical and that can increase
the rate of chemical reactions that's
sort of a
something goes a little bit beyond just
saying what's the total concentration of
this chemical and that chemical and
that's what will determine the chemical
processes that are going on but in a
first approximation that's the story
and similarly in in biology from from uh
back
uh well if you've gone back i don't know
80 years or something that would be um
uh the story of how you would imagine
that biology had to work at a sort of
chemical biochemical level
but then big discovery was made 1953
uh that dna
was a single molecule that could store
lots of information a single molecule
that way we didn't just have to say
oh it's a it's a hemoglobin
molecule or something or it's a molecule
has some other name you had to say both
it's a dna molecule and has this
particular genetic code
so i mentioned that proteins are made up
of these strings of amino acids
um
the uh any particular protein hemoglobin
happens to be one i don't know actin
uh
ferritin lots of different um proteins
that make us up each protein has a
certain uh specific sequence of amino
acids that make up that protein
well
uh for dna
it's a sequence of nucleic acids and um
the uh
um
the the thing that exists there is that
there can be
the dna molecule is can have any
sequence of these base pairs and so
instead of just being a particular
instead of just saying it's a dna
molecule that's all we have to say about
it we actually have to say well it's a
dna molecule with the sequence a t g c a
t t et cetera et cetera and that can go
on for for a billion uh base pairs and
it can store
essentially a billion bits of
information so so that single molecule
can kind of pack in tons of information
and that information is what our
through the mechanisms of of uh that's
that's what specifies how proteins
should be constructed and so on in our
cells
so
right now in molecular biology
one imagines that well yes these
individual dna molecules and rna
molecules that can have
store all this information but when it
comes to the other molecules that are
hanging around in one cells like
proteins and so on
once you know it's this kind of protein
or that kind of protein that's all you
need to know
it's not clear that's correct
there's another possibility
when you look at the interactions
between these molecules
you typically will just the only thing
you'll usually be asking is
right now is
what's the total concentration of each
molecule how many molecules are there of
this particular kind but actually
there's a lot more information that
matters for example it could be the case
that these two molecules they collided
with each other they reacted they
exchanged some atoms
they changed their structure then they
break apart again they go off and then
well maybe those two same molecules come
back and collide again
but the state of
the the state that they were in matters
to how what happens when they
subsequently collide or alternatively
this whole kind of you can make this
whole kind of network of the sort of
histories of individual atoms
and that is much more detailed
information than just saying oh there's
a total of this number of this kind of
atom instead you've got this whole dance
of what's happening to each atom or each
molecule i should say and um
you can either say what's the total
concentration of these molecules or you
can ask kind of what's the whole dance
of the interaction between these
molecules it's my guess that there's
actually a lot of information in
molecular biology that is essentially
stored
in this sort of dynamical you know
the progression with time of which
molecule interacts with which one and
how does that how does that molecule
then come back and interact with the
other molecule again and so on so in
other words that it isn't just the
concentration of chemicals that matters
to the operational biological systems
but also this much more detailed
choreography much more detailed kind of
uh arrangement of of
the which molecule interacts with which
other one and and which particular
molecule is then going to do some other
interaction and so on and so it's my
guess that that is important in the
operation of biological organisms
and that perhaps that's part of what one
has been missing in not being able to
explain in sort of the big picture many
features of how biological organisms
work and phenomena like aging and so on
which have been a little difficult to
make sort of a a large-scale statement
about
and um
and similarly also the operation of the
immune system where we know a certain
amount about how it works but there are
lots of mysteries about how it works
and perhaps part of the reason for that
is that we're kind of looking at the
wrong aspects of of of the system and we
have to look more at this kind of
dynamical network of what's going on
so
uh that um
so
our physics project provides kind of a
formalism for thinking about those kinds
of dynamic networks because it's exactly
those dynamic networks in our physics
project that make up the structure of
physical space
well we can apply the same ideas
to understand these kind of networks of
interaction between molecules and so on
and i think that might be really
important for understanding how
biological systems work
particularly in something like the
immune system
where we know that there are
interactions between the immune system
cells we don't really have a good way of
representing or thinking about the sort
of dynamical interactions between these
cells
different from just the the there's a
there's a some nasty antigen that comes
in from the outside and
collectively uh
some number of different uh you know
antibodies
are produced or some such other thing
this is asking within that whole
collection of antibodies and b cells and
t cells and all this kind of thing what
is the kind of uh what are the all the
interactions between those different
kinds of cells that happen uh in in the
immune system
so
uh
the the kind of the thought there is
uh
perhaps these these kinds of dynamical
processes are important for
understanding biology and if you're
interested in making drugs for example
that have biological effects
those may be things that are important
to take into account
the typical drug
the it's it's basic strategy is be a
molecule of a certain shape
and fit into a molecule of another shape
and have an effect on it so some drugs
will inhibit some particular process by
if there's some protein for example
proteins are usually folded up in some
complicated shape and they'll have
little little sort of holes in in the
side of the protein from from where the
uh where the atoms and the protein were
arranged there'll be some little hole
and some other molecule just very
conveniently fits into that hole and
causes the protein to do this or that
thing and that's part of how
how the biological organism works but if
you can have a drug that will fit into
that hole where the other molecule is
supposed to go in and it'll lock itself
into that hole it prevents the other
molecule from getting in there and
that's kind of a mechanism that a drug
can use or alternatively it can it can
do sort of the opposite and and
make some change attach itself somewhere
to a protein and make it easier for
another molecule to attach itself and to
have something happen so a very typical
kind of strategy for drugs for the
couple of thousand a couple of thousand
drugs that have been uh uh developed
well they're more that have been
developed that's the number that are in
use
um the uh uh and they all have different
detailed strategies but it's very often
this kind of
sort of puzzle piece fitting together
kind of idea that they make use of
now there's a question of what if it
matters what kind of the dynamical
processes the of of of the kind of uh
the the um
how these molecules move around and
interact with each other and then
re-interact and so on how does that
affect what one can do
in terms of uh
making changes to the system through
introducing other molecules well it's an
interesting question i think that
question is is most uh
immediate for the immune system
where
there are
things that are clearly happening in the
immune system sometimes leading to
diseases like autoimmune diseases where
the immune system is is more active than
it should be
and that's quite possibly something to
do with the interaction of the immune
system with itself
and these kind of dynamical processes
and so there's a question of of can one
uh come on go in and
make use of the ideas that we have from
our physics project to kind of see what
would you actually have to do to change
those dynamical processes to have an
effect on how the immune system works
so those are those are a few ideas there
um i think that the the main thing is
kind of what's the strategy by which
some particular
drug should work is it fit into this
particular whole what's the particular
target
that the drug should should uh should go
for and often those targets are very
directly sort of physical pieces
physical uh
sort of constructs
in in protein molecules or whatever else
this is a somewhat more a complicated
target because it's a target which
involves kind of the time dependence of
what's going on
and you know one of the things i think
is an early challenge there
is
if indeed it's important what this kind
of time history of interactions in
molecules is like can measure that
in in biology can we measure what what's
going on at that level
one of the tricks that has been used a
lot
to understand things in at the genomic
level to understand what is the sequence
of this piece of dna or rna or whatever
else
is
this technique called pcr polymerase
chain reaction
where essentially what one is doing
is taking
is is making many many copies of a
particular sequence that exists in rna
or dna
and once uh one has something when
typically goes through many cycles where
one's doubling the number of
of copies at every cycle so you know
people in in trying to detect for
example the uh rna from viruses and
things like that um people will sort of
say oh you know we saw a signal with 20
cycles of pcr which means that there
were
20 doublings so there were two to the
20th copies of whatever the initial
thing was or maybe
we needed 40 cycles of pcr to see a
signal so that means there were 2 to the
40th
multiplication of of the original
concentration of that dna molecule
but so what pcr does is it tells you a
particular sequence
um that exists in rna that may be a
sequence that exists in the virus you're
trying to look for and doesn't exist
anywhere in us humans pcr allows you to
amplify that sequence and see whether
it's present in a particular sample
so what one would need is kind of an
analog of that to amplify the effects of
these kind of dynamical processes and
see was there this particular cycle of
these particular molecules present in
this
in this system but i don't know how to
do that yet and that's kind of a
challenge to invent something like pcr
that is sensitive to dynamical processes
and cells rather than the static just
the static structure of a dna molecule
or something
let's see
uh
well
um
so question here i think i talked about
this in another
another
session here but there's a question here
about
cryonics
and freezing humans and so on
and uh
it's uh
i've often felt that
there are these different moments in
kind of medical discovery
when people
suddenly are able to do something that
they were never able to do before so for
example antibiotics
drugs that
will kill bacterial cells and leave
our
eukaryotic our sort of
uh higher higher animal type cells un
unaffected
and
sort of the idea that one could have a
molecule that would kind of
attack bacteria
and not attack
higher organism cells that was something
that that was from the 1930s 40s
that was kind of a dramatic
uh
sort of um
uh moment in the history of medicine
um
in in kind of biology in general
another moment that
well many many of these things i mean
the the idea of stem cells and the idea
of being able to
uh
the idea that so so
in in us
we have oh maybe a few thousand
different types of cells
from hair cells to brain cells to muscle
cells
all these different kinds of cells
yet we all start off from just a single
cell
and the question is how do we
differentiate into all these different
kinds of cells
and
so
if you want to for example replace some
kind of cells
a sort of
um
famous example of that is
replacing the beta cells of the pancreas
that produce insulin
um if you want to replace cells
in uh
what you would like to be able to do is
to sort of re-run
the process of going from that single
single egg cell to all the different
kinds of cell types that exist in in us
humans as as we are as sort of adult
humans
um and the question is how do you how
does that differentiation occur
um and uh
for a long time it was really not
knowing at all
how that occurred because what happens
is every cell in our bodies has the same
ultimate dna the same basic instructions
about what proteins it can make
but what happens in different cell types
is that
different parts of that dna are
activated and different parts of that
dna um get get to make the proteins that
that make hair or or
or
brain cells or lung cells or whatever
else
and so it was it was quite mysterious
what
uh what was the mechanism by which
those different
parts of one's of the dna in a
particular cell got activated
and um
the uh
and it was finally more or less figured
out i don't know a couple of decades ago
um more or less how that works
um and how different sort of things that
that attached to the dna
make it um uh and and different uh
different
different things that that uh sort of
promote the the um the making of
proteins from one part of the dna rather
rather than another part of dna how that
works and how different
how sort of the starting off from this
this initial kind of uh single cell how
you end up with
this kind of cell followed by that kind
of cell followed by that kind of cell
the whole kind of tree of what kinds of
cells exist in humans i don't think
there's a complete map yet of that sort
of tree of cells in humans
there's a particular kind of organism
the nematode the c elegans it's a little
kind of microscopic worm thing
where it is known in precise detail how
every single cell in that organism uh
how it how it is produced it only has a
couple of thousand cells in it um and uh
so it's sort of easier to trace what
happens and and that particular organism
with its couple of thousand cells pretty
much every organism is identical well
for us humans there's like well you're
going to have a big lump of of nerve
cells and different people will have
those particular nerve cells arranged in
detail in different ways but in the in
the nematodes and c elegans they're
really
arranged in an identical way and so in
that particular case the complete sort
of uh tree of how you go from the
initial cell to all the particular you
know muscle like cells and and uh they
even have some eye like cells and brain
cells and so on how how those um
different kinds of cells arise
that's not i think completely known yet
for us humans and it's even not known
how many types of cells really exist in
humans
and
some are very obvious but particularly
among brain cells there can be many
different variants so among well types
of blood cells it's like is it really a
different type of cell because it has
sort of different
things attached to the surface of the
cell or or not
it's sort of a complicated story but the
thing that's been learnt is how to go
from a stem cell to
a
two different kinds of cells so i think
um like pancreatic beta cells i think
they're like 12 steps you have to go
through you go to this kind of cell to
that kind of cell to that kind of cell
and eventually you wind up with a beta
cell and it's been slowly learnt how to
kind of coax cells to go through these
different stages of division because for
a while it wasn't clear how you could
get stem cells
so-called pluripotent
um
stem cells with the potential to turn
into anything
and it was thought the only way you
could get them was to go back to fetal
tissue and
go back to kind of um where we all start
from so to speak um and and go forward
from there but what was discovered um oh
i don't know what it was 15 years ago
maybe
was how to take sort of any old cell
that we have and how to get it to go
back to the state where it is not yet
differentiated
and to say forget about all those
special
uh this special overlay that you have to
tell you to turn into a skin cell
actually be a stem cell which can turn
into any possible cell and by the way
one of the reasons it's important to
have
uh stem cells
you might say
why
uh well
because each of us has a slightly
different genetic code and our immune
systems are key to our particular
genetic code that means if you want to
uh
for example one thing you you might try
to do
is to make cells that are a particular
kind of cell
for a particular person so to speak you
can also make them generically sort of
for for anybody um but then
then you end up you have that type of
cell but you still have the immune
system of a particular person will tend
to go and attack that cell and in order
to make use of these things medically
you have to suppress the immune system
or you have to enclose that cell in some
kind of uh in some kind of little bag
where where like chemicals can go in and
out that are useful but the immune
system can't get into effect to to kind
of
notice that there's something foreign in
there
i suppose one one of the things that's a
recent um kind of uh
uh
direction i mean people have been trying
this for ages but i think it's recently
started to work is this idea of uh
taking other animals i don't know pigs
whatever else
and giving them enough sort of
human-like genome
uh that that for the purpose of growing
a particular kind of organ or particular
kind of cell
you can have those grow in a pig for
example and then you can transplant them
into a human um and that's a medical for
medical purposes
but i think the um uh this so
um anyway this this um i was just saying
that sort of if we look at the history
of medicine and biology and so on there
these moments where things get
discovered like stem cells like how to
coax cells and
and to differentiate them in particular
ways like how to edit a genome uh it's
it's now possible there are all kinds of
complicated restrictions and constraints
but basically in theory it's possible to
we've imagined that our dna whatever
we're born with is what we're stuck with
um we've known that there are
retroviruses that can go in and try and
in certain pieces into our dna and in
fact we can see in the history of human
dna there are lots of kinds of places
where that happened historically in the
in the dna that that gets passed down
through our species
um but it's now known how to actually go
in and sort of on demand edit certain
pieces of of our of our genome
and so that these different sort of
moments where sort of a essentially
basic research discovery gets made and
then it has many medical consequences so
another discovery that was made in the
1990s was how to do mammalian cloning
how to take an organism
and make essentially a copy of that
organism
and so
it uh and that relates again to a lot of
this stuff about stem cells and
differentiation and so on how do you
like take a skin cell from from an adult
organism for example and go back and
sort of replay the developments of that
organism from
uh by by taking that
that cell and going back and um
and being able to to make a copy of the
organism and so that's been done for
well all kinds of organisms um it's uh
people think it's a pretty bad idea to
do it for humans it was originally done
for a sheep um it's been done for uh
cats i think i think there's a i think
there was a i don't know it's still
around but there was a
company called copycat that would um uh
copy your cat
the same with dogs things like that
um
the uh the question of sort of what is
the clone like and is the clone sort of
up to the standards of the original and
so on i think the general impression is
that it it more or less is maybe there
are some slight
uh things that aren't quite uh up to
snuff for the original but it's pretty
close
but that's another thing that is kind of
a a sort of an idea that it's possible
to do that and for many years people
said
oh yes it's possible to clone lower
organisms but it'll never be possible to
clone mammals
why
well it's just too complicated we don't
know how to do it
so there wasn't really a good reason but
it was just nobody had figured out how
to do it and then there was this
discovery made in the 1990s that did
involve some pretty weird things like
electrical shocks to cells and to egg
cells and things like this
that um
uh
was um
uh yeah i should have said that you
don't need the whole
stem cell story what you need is to
extract the dna to extract the genetic
code for the organism that you want to
make the copy of extract that which you
can do from any cell in the body and
insert that into an egg cell and have
that uh be produce sort of the
copy of that same organism
but um
uh but you still have this problem of
well if there's been something done to
the dna that is what makes it be a skin
cell rather than something else you have
to kind of reverse that out
but any case those are sort of examples
of of
biological advances that well in the
case of cloning hasn't i think turned
into
a particular medical advance at least
not for sort of higher organisms the
concept of monoclonal antibodies being
able to just make lots and lots and lots
of identical antibodies that's become an
important medical idea but that's a
quite that's a different level of thing
from the cloning a sheep type type idea
but so one of the things which where
it's like well nobody figured out how to
do it yet but there's no sort of proof
that it's impossible
is how to freeze an organism and um and
bring it back to life so to speak
and people
there are
fishes for example that get frozen in
ice and uh you know for winter and then
seem to be perfectly happy uh sort of uh
coming back to life in the in the spring
kind of thing and the question is why
doesn't that work
for uh
for us higher organisms why can't you
just
uh take a person and freeze them and you
know it's been an idea in science
fiction forever you know you're going to
go on a long space mission you know just
freeze the people while the spacecraft
is is going to the wherever it's going
to go to and then uh you know unfreeze
them again
and uh uh note you know that it's like
they've just been been in suspended
animation so to speak all of that time
and uh it's it's all good
the question is can i actually do that
in practice
the main problem is
that we are full of water
and water
is a substance that has the the strange
and annoying property that when it
freezes into ice it gets bigger
and most materials
in their solid phase when the when the
molecules are packed together more
closely they're smaller than when
they're in the liquid phase and all the
molecules are jumping around but water
for complicated reasons
doesn't have that property it gets
bigger when it freezes
and that has sort of a disastrous effect
and it's you know
it happens when you put fruit in a
freezer or something as well
that the the water
in in the uh in the tissue will expand
and that means that if it's inside a
cell and the
cell is has a bunch of water in it the
the water will expand and it will burst
the cell walls and so you get this kind
of mushy mess
of uh of sort of frozen fruit or
something and so the problem is if
you're going to do that to an organism
like us
that's absolutely not what you want to
have happen you want to have the cells
be preserved and just the water in them
frozen what effect does it have to
freeze them well the reason that that is
important is that the chemical reactions
that uh represent kind of us doing all
the things we do when we're alive those
chemical reactions happen in liquid
phase they happen when the molecules are
able to run around as they do in a
liquid and interact with other molecules
if you freeze them into a solid the
molecules are locked in place and they
can't have those kinds of reactions and
so it's as if so the organism whatever
reactions lead the organism to get old
the organism to need to eat food the
organism to do all these kinds of things
all of those are stopped if you can just
freeze it into solid form and more to
the point the rate of reactions goes
down as you decrease the temperature and
if you can make the temperature low
enough you can expect that the reactions
will basically stop
and so then the question is well how do
you get is there a way to sort of freeze
things without
going through this awkward stage of the
water expanding
and well nobody knows how to do that and
so their ideas of using sort of
anti-freeze type agents
that
will sort of avoid the the place where
well okay so another thing i should
explain
when when water freezes into ice at zero
degrees centigrade in um at standard
pressure
then it has this feature that it gets
bigger
if you can get water down to i think
it's minus 44 degrees centigrade
um
then it will turn into this phase
um
that uh
um it's a kind of glossy phase instead
of in in ice
that there are many different kinds of
ice
but in ordinary ice
the molecules are arranged in this kind
of hexagonal array in a very regular
hexagonal array they're different kinds
of ice for example if you're in glacier
where there's ice under very high
pressure you'll get a different crystal
arrangement you'll get a different
arrangement of water molecules i think
there are at least nine ten different
kinds of of structures of ice that are
known that occur at different pressures
and so on but in any case if you can get
uh water down to the point where it's
so-called vitrifies
which means that its molecules are all
sort of frozen in place
but they're randomly arranged they're
not arranged in this kind of regular
array that corresponds to a crystal
they're arranged in the way that for
example molecules in glass are arranged
where they're sort of all randomly it's
a solid more or less
i say more or less because even glass
like in a window will slowly flow over
the course of a century or something it
will slowly deform
and uh that's a feature of the fact that
the molecules are not like locked in
place in this array as they are in a
crystal but uh the um
in the case of water if you can get
water down to the point where it is
turning into this glassy phase
then it does not expand uh that that
phase is is smaller than the liquid
phase
and uh the problem is getting from zero
degrees centigrade to minus 44 degrees
centigrade uh things don't just
instantaneously
cool down like that
to cool something down what you're doing
is you're removing heat from the thing
removing heat well heat is the motion of
molecules that's what that heat that
that's what heat is
is this energy associated with the
motion of molecules and so what you want
to do is you want to quickly suck out
that energy and get the temperature down
to the point where where when the
molecules are down at that temperature
the the water will not expand it will
not arrange itself in this in this way
that corresponds to a larger volume and
so on
but
nobody knows how to do that
now the um the sort of the good news i
suppose is that
uh our in our bodies our bloodstream
delivers oxygen to our tissues and it's
arranged so that little tiny capillaries
i mean our our bloodstream has a
circulatory system
has sort of big arteries and and veins
and so on and then those branch into
smaller capillaries and they keep
branching they keep branching and as
as
one grows there are more uh
those those capillaries keep forming
and
they get to the point where they're so
small that they're within two millionths
of a meter basically of any place in our
body there is some capillary and that's
important because
when
oxygen is delivered through our blood
it's getting into these capillaries and
then it's diffusing just the oxygen
molecules are diffusing into tissues
where they're used to let the tissues be
able to operate and generate energy and
so on
so so conveniently we have the system
that delivers
stuff to within two microns of any place
in our body the question is if we wanted
to freeze
uh if we wanted to sort of get frozen
quickly can we use that to kind of get
something to within two microns of every
place in our body and and would that
work
well people don't know how to do that
yet
there are it's sort of a problem of the
physics of water as much as it is
anything else
people talk about all kinds of things
with
um
i've heard things about
liquid helium
that has various kinds of viscosity
properties that allow it to quickly get
into different places things like this
different approaches i've sort of
imagined that there might be some
approaches based on external
electromagnetic fields that could have
an effect on the way that molecules work
and so on different kinds of ideas but
nobody really knows how to do this yet
and
the
there's also
it's easier
for very direct reasons it's easier to
do it for a mouse than it is for do it
to for a human because a mouse is a lot
smaller and if you want to sort of get
the cold into a part of the mouse
it is it sort of takes less effort to do
that than it does with a bigger human so
to speak
um and but you know there's there's the
question of okay if you froze all these
tissues um what would be preserved would
everything be preserved um when you if
you sort of warm it back up again and
what would you have to do you know as
you as it's a it's a
a common feature of um uh various kinds
of surgeries that you cool things down
to uh to make sort of things happen more
slowly
and um clearly when you frozen things
things like you know the heart isn't
beating and so on because it's frozen
solid um and sort of uh you have to
think how do you restart all these
things how do you get um uh how do you
get
the the system sort of back up and
running and will it will it come back in
the form that it got frozen in and for
example one question would be will
memories in the brain
get destroyed by being frozen well right
now the best sort of the the it's still
at the point where
um
well we don't know how to preserve any
cells because they all have water in
them and they all have this problem of
expanding when they're frozen um but the
question of for example whether there's
something about let's say human memories
that will be destroyed by being frozen
like that not knowing my guess in that
particular case is no my guess is that
the um uh that the way that memories are
stored in the brain
is probably through these little calcium
channels that exist and things like that
in the in the membranes
between
nerve cells and that those are fairly
rugged robust things that won't be
affected by by sort of uh freezing
the um the operation of the organism but
we don't know that for sure um so you
know i kind of think that this is one of
these things where one day somebody will
just say up we got cryonics to work and
it'll it'll work because there's some
exotic kind of chemical that's used
that's uh that's infused into the
bloodstream and and uh uh it might work
pretty much like it works in the science
fiction movies in the end um it's uh uh
it's kind of surprising that um
rather little work ends up getting done
on these things that sometimes i think
that science fiction movies are a
double-edged sword in terms of the
advance of science and technology
because people see things in science
fiction movies
and they kind of get used to the idea of
that's the way the future will be
and that's provides kind of a direction
for people to think about things for the
future but on the other hand the fact
that the thing showed up in a science
fiction movie makes some kinds of kind
of scientists say oh that's just science
fiction we shouldn't actually try to do
that it's just science fiction so to
speak so i think it's a it's sort of a
complicated combination and i kind of
think cryonics is a little bit uh the
victim of um it's been in science
fiction so it can't be real type thing
but my assumption is that eventually it
will be real and eventually it will be
perfectly possible for us to just sort
of say oh
uh you know there's some medical
condition which we don't know how to
cure right now let's just get frozen for
a decade and uh wait until that's
figured out and then
uh come back and and be cured of that
disease or whatever and that will be
very cool if that works
um uh i for one
uh particularly because i'm interested
in kind of science and things like that
that has pretty long time horizons i'd
be really interested to see what happens
a long time from now and uh in sort of
ordinary uh without cryonics or
something like that one doesn't just
doesn't get to see what happens in 150
years it's not not a plausible thing
so
gosh well let's see
um
a lot of different questions here
uh
sometimes you guys ask questions where i
just have no idea what the answer is
there's a question here from jamie is it
true that cats domesticated themselves
compared to other animals that humans
domesticated for a purpose
i simply don't know
the uh
although it sounds quite plausible
it is an interesting question
what animals
uh sort of
can successfully be
quotes domesticated and i suppose
you know a famous example i don't know
how true this is but it's certainly said
to be true
is that while horses while you can sort
of tame horses
it's much harder to tame zebras even
though zebras are
incredibly close
sort of biologically to horses but for
whatever reason zebras
are
uh just sort of um have enough of a
different
way of operating that they don't agree
to have somebody put a you know a horse
bridle on them or something like that
at least that's what what i've heard
and so it does raise the question
what kinds of organisms
are
compatible with kind of
hanging out with humans i mean we see
you know i don't think there are a lot
of domesticated deer for example or i
don't think there are domesticated
kangaroos maybe i'm wrong about that um
i think that uh uh and there are
things like horses
or dogs where humans found very specific
purposes
where those animals could do things that
were useful for humans
and humans could kind of interface with
them well enough to be able to get them
to you know on demand go and sniff
something or on demand go and walk in
this direction or whatever else
and i think it's
it's an interesting question
what other kinds of organisms what other
kinds of animals
are in principle domesticatable
or have attributes
that we care about
domesticating i mean for example there
are plenty of animals with excellent
senses of smell
um relative to us humans
dogs are the main one that we use for
their sense of smell
but probably there are lots of others
that
could also be used
but we haven't kind of gone through that
path of domesticating them and
understanding how to interact with them
and so on i mean i i do wonder to some
extent
to what extent
we
bred something like dogs to be kind of
ones the the dogs that were more
suitable for us to interface with and to
what extent we simply learnt
what were methods by which we could
train dogs and by which we could
essentially communicate with dogs and
which sort of where the learning
happened was it in the breeding of the
organism or was it more in knowing how
for us humans how we interface with the
organism i mean i'm not sure it's it's
self-evident that you would like um put
a thing in the mouth of a horse or
something to be able to tell it you know
go this way or that way um somebody had
to discover that uh and um i i kind of
have a feeling a bunch of people got
bitten by by by doing that but that's
that's uh that would just be a guess
but i think
um
in um
so
i mean i do wonder quite a bit
what particularly in modern times
whether
now that we have all kinds of sensors
and all kinds of actuators you know i do
wonder about you know if you put sort of
if you put some some strange helmet on
some kind of uh critter um that that
would be a sort of great way for us to
interface with that critter um or put
you know put i don't know what on or or
give or put you know um little uh um uh
you know airpod like things in the ears
of the critter um have it uh um
and you also don't know you know another
thing that's super hard to determine
is well does the organism
and even it's not clear how one should
feel about it does the organism like to
have
be in this situation or that situation i
mean it it appears to us that cats
like to be
you know
uh lying in front of a fire or something
else created by humans that is the
impression is that that cats like that
um many cats like that and cats don't
like being you know dunked in water or
something um and uh
but you know this question of if we
could find some some way of putting you
know air pods on the in on the um
i don't know on the elephant or
something uh you know
it might have a grand old time or it
might not
and could we even tell if it was having
grand old time or not and one of the
things that
is sort of an important observation
about is that emotions seem to be a
thing that is more or less conserved
that we more or less share
with with many kinds of animals um and
that's a thing for example charles
darwin pointed that out a sort of
evidence
for the evolutionary connections between
humans and animals that there were sort
of shared features of emotional
responses between for example dogs and
and humans that you know kind of the
expressions dogs make when they're
annoyed
um are similar to the ones humans make
when they're annoyed and so on and that
that that kind of uh
that we can kind of see a commonality
between our emotional states and the
emotional states of these kinds of
animals so we can reasonably say oh you
know playing that kind of music to an
elephant it's having a grand old time
versus doing that it hates that
um and i think but but i think it is a
an interesting question whether with
modern technology there are different
kinds of uh sort of domestication paths
for animals that didn't exist before um
and perhaps uh
ways that one could uh uh even well ways
that one can learn from the animals or
find out things from the animals in ways
that weren't possible before because
we're just able to collect a lot more
data and able to notice a lot more kinds
of things i mean it's certainly within
the realm of possibility that you know
there are i don't know languages forms
of communication between animals and so
on where as soon as we notice that as
soon as we notice you know like bees
have this kind of dance that they do
um that uh
explains things to their hive mates
about sort of where to go find where to
go forage for pollen and so on um but
one had to discover that that sort of
dancing thing that bees were doing had
some kind of communication purpose that
we humans can understand and so there's
sort of a question
for other kinds of animals is it just
like oh we just didn't notice
that
this particular you know kind of um
uh motion from cats you know that cats
were doing this or that thing i think
cats are that excited about
communicating with other with other with
other cats but but
maybe something that's more of a pack
animal um might be more excited about
that but that that these things that
they're doing that we didn't even notice
are the key part of their communication
process i mean like for for example for
uh insects
pheromones the these molecules that um
they uh
smelling molecules that they can smell
that they'll sort of coat things with
actually that's done by by even dogs and
so on too that um they'll sort of mark
out territory with molecules um and one
kind of has to know to look for that um
before and can tell what's going on and
so there's certainly the within the
range of possibility that there are sort
of features of the behavior of animals
but we just didn't notice
and as soon as we notice
we're like able to say oh yeah you know
that means this or that
thing in dog speak or whatever um and uh
i i've sort of felt that this is
actually a pretty good application of
some modern kind of data science machine
learning kinds of things to finally
figure out and maybe we'll discover
that either there isn't any such
language or communication or if there is
it will be communication about things
that
are
uh well there might be things about
which we absolutely do not care as
humans at this time in history i mean it
might be the the dog is explaining oh
there's a you know there's a green smell
over there or oh that's a very uh you
know that's a very elegant collection of
different smells that are coming from
this this particular direction
well for us it's like smell art of that
kind is not something that we're
normally into so it's something where we
might say well that's nice for the dogs
but we don't really care
um and one can imagine sort of forms of
communication about things that are yes
well that's good if you have a sensory
system that has this or that
characteristics then that's something
that um will be important to you but for
us humans where we're you know sight and
sound and so on it doesn't really matter
much to us so that that's something that
could happen or it could be that another
thing that could be communicated would
be i don't know that their cats are
communicating oh there's this
complicated social hierarchy of cats and
you know it really matters that oh that
cat over there is is uh you know in this
place in the social hierarchy of cats
and while that might be interesting to
some zoologists or ethologists um
um
ethnologists um it would be um
it would be something where for us
humans it would leave us kind of cold
perhaps as perhaps as sometimes uh for
us old fogies the um uh sort of the the
social order of the young ends on
various social media platforms and
things leaves on a bit cold why do
people care you know this particular
configuration of followers or whatever
else and we might find if you know if we
could communicate with the animals that
they're obsessed with their with their
likes
in um in you know in cat media so to
speak um and we might say
that's that's great for you cats we just
don't care um and uh i think but but
it's an interesting question whether
whether there are kind of things where
we could
uh you know we could decode what's going
on
in a way that we can at least
provide something which is relatable for
us
i mean it's the first question is is
there anything going on and the second
question is is what's going on something
that is relatable to us humans where we
can have the cat to human translator and
have it turn into
oh you know that's a i'm really keen on
that kind of cat food or um
did you know that um uh you know did you
know that every day there's a mouse that
comes out of that hole in your wall and
um uh you know and comes and uh eats
things in in this place or something you
know you know
cat bulletin that's you know a thing
that the cat can explain kind of thing
you know those are things which might be
human relatable whereas there might be
other things which are sort of uh
forms of communication that we're just
not going to
uh
we're not going to care about now now
having said that one could imagine let's
say that the cat
is extremely keen on explaining
that uh
oh i don't know there's some a
particular
thing
has you know if they rub their whiskers
against this particular thing the little
electrical effect on their whiskers is
really really nice and that's a
wonderful texture
and you know get more of that kind of
chair because it's it's a great place to
you know rub whiskers or something and
and we might say well as us humans
that's not really an important thing but
of course
in
as as for example we
get more maybe not in that particular
example i i don't really think that the
human whisker uh
you know technology is is necessarily um
that uh likely to come to pass
but um one can imagine as we kind of
have more sensory apparatus let's say
for example that uh if we could talk to
bees they might tell us oh there's this
amazing thing that you can see in the
ultraviolet where they happen to their
vision extends into the into the
ultraviolet there's this amazing thing
in the ultraviolet and you should really
care about this and you should build
things that have these characteristics
in the ultraviolet and at this time in
history we might say we don't really
care but at some time in the future
when we all have you know augmented
reality devices and things
and those augmented reality devices can
perfectly all have cameras that see into
the ultraviolet um that might be that
our current visual system which is
normally fed just with visible light is
also routinely sensing what's happening
in the ultraviolet and so we might be oh
yes you know we really now care about
these things that the that the bees have
noticed and so on
all right i think i'm going off into
into um
uh
um
uh
very bizarre territory here but i think
for me this whole question of sort of
communicating
with uh
uh
with things that have a different view
of the world
is
i for me it's an interesting thing
because it helps us kind of understand
how to think about
how to think about all sorts of things i
mean in a sense as we look at the
progress of science
a lot of the important steps in the
progress of science have to do with
looking at things in a different way
and in a sense we can get clues about
that if there is some existing
uh kind of
tradition or something
that sort of always looks at things in
some different way whether it's a human
tradition or whether it's a a tradition
in some other organism or something
that's uh that's an interesting piece of
raw material for
for us to make use of i mean it's it's
something where for example the science
we have
mostly comes out of a
sort of western historical tradition um
it's not obvious whether there are
things that can be woven together from
other traditions that might be super
useful for science unfortunately by the
time one has got a certain distance in
one tradition it's much harder to kind
of attach things from other traditions
because sort of built this big tower of
ideas based on one particular tradition
and these other traditions just don't
really attach to that in a good way but
that's the kind of thing one might hope
for
all right i should um
uh
i should probably uh wrap up here for
now but um
thanks for joining me this was a
slightly uh we had some uh
going we ended up going off into some
slightly unexpected directions today
um but uh happy to talk about all these
kinds of things i always
learn things from from trying to think
things through that i don't usually
think through
so thank you for priming uh for
prompting that to happen
um and uh reminder that um you can send
in topics you want to talk about
on the uh
on a form
whose location i do not immediately know
but uh hopefully somebody can put it in
chat
um
and uh otherwise look forward to seeing
you